- Speaking of Miley.
This was one of my favorite
things I've heard recently.
So she shared her experience with UFO's,
which I do believe life is out there,
but you've had a similar experience.
I didn't know that.
- (laughing) Well I don't
talk about it all that often
to be honest, but you know,
it goes back, when I was a little boy
growing up in Kentucky,
there was this place
back in the mountains,
and there's these big old
beach trees back there.
And beach trees are good
to carve on with a knife
and way back in the 1930s,
a guy that lived back in the mountains
had had this experience with,
he carved the pictures on a tree.
I found them when I was a little boy
and it was an old model
T Ford and a saucer
and this alien looking thing.
And I started researching
and I go, wait man,
there was like an alien
invasion in Kentucky
in the late 1930's, who knew about that.
- Why not?
- Yeah, and so I kind
of got, I don't know,
fascinated with it as a little boy.
And then a couple of times,
you know, throughout life
I've seen some crazy stuff.
Some of it I'm sure most of
it's probably explainable,
but some of it, I liked-
Hey, I took that picture.
- [Kelly] He said, hey. (laughing)
- I remember that one right
there, that's a beauty.
I took that.
With my Blackberry.
- With my Blackberry, iPhone. (laughing)
So wait, Rainn and Lisa do y'all believe?
Lisa, do you believe in extraterrestrial?
- I do, I do.
- I don't think it's what we think it is.
- I know.
- But I do believe in like other life.
- I think that just can't,
we can't be the only life.
- [Kelly] I think that's so
egocentric to think that.
- I think so, too.
- Right, I mean unless
you don't believe in it
and then I think that's fine Rainn.
(Kelly laughing)
- Oh no, I totally believe that there's,
there's aliens and some
kind of they'd be traveling
and they'd be observing us, and right now
I think those aliens are
looking down on planet earth
and going.
- [Lisa] Yes.
(Kelly laughing)
- [Lisa] I would agree.
- They're behind the curve,
they just can't figure it out.